Oh No was he evil oh yeah at all yeah
he's not shaping up to be cool oh this
is a bad snowman oh hi
well now you're surprised that I'm here
sorry I was looking in that direction
for what purpose
hey guys it's a wall I invited you here
because I wanted to show you a cartoon I
know the premise of this bit this is my
home I've been living here for Oh
you've been living here yeah it's now an
in-house production studio you're the
new Walt Disney what are we watching
speaking of Walt Disney it's a Disney
it's not a dis no so that's a weird
segue well okay here's the deal it's not
a Disney it's called the Snowman it's
from 1932 this is there's a weird movie
called the Snowman the where it's an
animated movie don't drift off on me no
it's where the kid holds the snowman's
hand he's going through the sky it's
like it's this I mean I'm doing the
Jurassic North him that's what just
happened was crazy in your mind
there's a guy named Teddy Ashbaugh I
believe you say a Canadian guy Walt
Disney was a huge fan okay such a huge
fan that he basically bought him out and
him over in the guy never worked
again cool cool cool cool and I think
it's gonna be the best thing we've ever
seen I have a feeling that that is not
the case it's your first time here right
no no no not at all
Jimmy go ahead and hit it
[Music]
told you fantasies in color that sounds
like Cinemax when I was a kid I mean
people are very excited about color
around this time sure I in cartoons not
in society no they hate it in society
it's kind of a creepy snowman logo but
the running letters people are gonna die
alright a lot of a lot of credits we
like that yeah
starts off nice and intense so as you
can see it's snowing yep
okay and when it's snowing you put your
seal outside and the good hot water
bottle yep
safe to say it's domesticated yeah or
ruined was another word sure
dear God please find another area to
live in
[Music]
so he is not going in yeah he's
hibernating and the dead animals looking
anyway like most people he's just gonna
sleep several months at a time just the
annual coma he's up the Bears got a mess
seriously the bear was dead yeah the
bear was dead to begin with well what
about when I licked him I mean that was
a weird moment whoa someone's been what
was seal a pelican oh yeah
chick it's weird up in the Arctic yes
all right and now let's have a little
dance well they're up they're awake it's
exciting mice and then these are fish
look I don't know anything about nature
but I don't like it well this stave was
when the North Pole wasn't melting you
can see right Walt Disney was jealous
yeah I know of course you want to hit
yourself to this train I mean this is
like watching a nature documentary yeah
sure hey would you be hungry you just
slept for six months now you gotta make
good about a bite and make a snowman
first it's called a snow nut get some
teeth there yeah they're gonna do the
teeth they speak English that's a weird
thing to hold on to for two minutes it's
kind of taking apart the infrastructure
of the city yeah anyway so this is like
a cult sort of thing this is what our
government does except it's a giant
rabbit
yeah they did it alright I'll see you
later alright Dave good to see you he
loves them he always has what's happened
he said it was high that's what's
happening this burning man oh god what
Gareth oh you did the dance to bring him
to life what did you think was gonna
happen no was he evil holy oh yeah yeah
he's not shaping up to be cool oh this
is a bad snowman it's definitely got
some sort of congestive issues I get the
sense that this guy's a prick he looks
like the guy from that shitty Rob Zombie
movie anyway that guy's out here well so
why did you bring him to life
this is incredibly slow yes uh-oh now
we've all been there yeah yeah oh lucky
it's a bad room yes guys not cool
anyway that's like that's a bad person
anyway he's got a but there's no ma'am
you don't see that snowman with butts
now I've always wondered about how their
intestines work oh just the old wall
risk penguin choir yeah they're really
into Church up there he died for our
sins
I want a clearer idea
I want the lyrics Oh God communion is
there anything worse than when an
uninvited snowman gets on the piano and
doesn't know how to play it Oh terrible
what he's really into himself he's kind
of getting the hang of it now I liked
his newer stuff yeah
oh okay up these guys are
innocent and stupid mm-hmm
leave the little one yeah you guys are
great parents yeah
oh is this climate change risky the
manifestation of climate change
mmm here's the bears the bear mice oh
the trunk bears now do you see where
Walt Disney might have taken a thing
here oh so this is pre a lot of the
Disney stuff yeah oh wow oh god
eat it not a lot of people in the eat at
Camp Dave really that Pelican was like
Beckett let's not show about well that's
what happens well you're idiot
go round
I feel like he's getting bigger I told
you to not pollute hmm that's an ass
nightmare mmm that is medically speaking
an ass nightmare hey what's that hey I
got in the furry thing polar bear rabbit
Pollard Oh awesome human skin what'd you
get what's happening right yeah this is
the president
I turn up the heat I mean this is how it
works by the way we don't know if it's
man-made yet no we do oh my god
smart now he'll melt with the ice caps
let's see that tushie bend over show us
the ass
[Music]
what about the rest of their land no the
fish is gonna die put the fish in the
water put the fish in the water fish is
celebrated no it's really working oxygen
efficiently further no nobody cares
about anything and when they make
cartoons I do like that it's called
fantasies
that's my what's your fantasy that's
lousy
it's a little off but it gets me off
every time yeah basically I always dream
about Helen going out of town for the
weekend and I sleep for six months and
then I make a big snowman he becomes
real and he's anti-human and anti-animal
just kind of anti-earth and then i go
inside of the glacier pentagon and I
turned the heat up until he melts yeah
something like that really thins my
pants what we're not recording these
right
[Music]
you